I'm not super comfortable putting myself
as the iteration on social media would
you do it in voice form absolutely I'm
not trying to Brand myself that's just
not what my interest is I do care about
the information and the teaching you can
write it and speak under a different
name okay you can literally audio on
your iPhone memos the information no
different than the way I do a video you
could literally use mid-journey an AI
tool and be like draw me a picture it's
insane what we can do today and you
don't have to put yourself out there it
would definitely not be disingenuine
you're trying to give away good
information I think it has a chance of
being slightly less effective because
humans connect with humans but you could
also flip it completely on its head and
could super win you might be able to
create a virtual character maybe you
draw a stick figure and that's what
shows up and talks people love Mickey
Mouse he's not alive